-The game works
like musical chairs
but instead of diving into
empty chairs,
we're grabbing
these red cups of beer.
When the music stops, one person
will be left empty-happened.
They are out of the game
and have to hang out
with our deejay,
DJ Mark Duane, upstage.
There he is. DJ Mark Duane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The last one standing is
the musical beers champion.
All right, everybody, space
yourselves out and get ready.
-All right.
-Quest, whenever you're ready,
start playing the music
and we'll start --
we'll start to walk around.
-I want to win this so bad.
-Yeah. Clockwise, yeah.
Yeah.
-Whoa, whoa, what are you doing?
Come on.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Almost out of here.
Almost out of here.
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nice playing, everybody.
-We throw them in now?
-You throw them in there.
-All right.
All right,
you've evened the odds.
I'll give you that.
-Evened the odds. Here we go.
-It's gonna ruin the show,
us not being in there.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, here we go.
-Over here?
-Does that count?
-My heart's beating so fast.
-I've never been more
intimidated in my whole life.
♪♪♪♪
-You got to take Jimmy's.
-Yeah.
-Let's work together.
We only need one of us to win.
-You go on that one then.
♪♪♪♪
-Ah!
-Oh, no.
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Want some of mine?
-Yeah.
-Make us proud, Michael.
-If you had the other one,
you would have still
been in the game.
And then there were four.
Thanks.
-All right, here we go.
-I knew it would be you and me,
Michael.
[ Indistinct talking ]
♪♪♪♪
-Are you moving at all?
Are you just gonna stand there?
-I'm watching you.
-Don't watch me, man.
-Don't even think about it.
Don't even --
[ Laughter ]
-Go on, yeah. Keep moving.
Keep moving. Keep it going.
[ Music stops ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's up, guys?
-I got another interview to do.
This is crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-Take him out, Drew!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, this is gonna get serious.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I thought
we were going this way.
-Why is he by himself?
Get him back!
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Don't touch that.
-Get away from him!
[ Laughter ]
-I can't hear the music.
♪♪♪♪
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo!
Come on, man!
That button broken or something?
-Hey.
-Oh, my gosh!
-He's out for blood.
-What's going on, dude?
-You played a good game.
-I'm out of breath, man.
-Really? We have to go
around the whole table?
-Here we go. Oh, my gosh.
♪♪♪♪
-It's a Chainsmoker
versus 5 S-O-S!
What's gonna happen?
♪♪♪♪
[ Music stops ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-The winner --
5 Seconds of Summer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our thanks to the Chainsmokers,
Questlove!